[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about what you need to know
about the users past and present of the
9 Titan powers before we get started I
want to give a quick shout out to the
attack on Titan Amino app I have been a
regular Amino user for a long time and
Amino has a wide variety of vibrant fan
communities that offer the perfect way
to interact with thousands of fellow
fans the attacks on Titan amino is the
best place to interact with other fans
in real time you can see who's online
you can live chat share fan art take
polls and discuss every new episode and
manga chapter as soon as they come out
we have our own anime uproar profile and
because we have been getting a ton of
requests for new attack on Titan videos
I created a poll where you guys can vote
for which video you want to see next the
poll will be up for a limited time only
so once you get the app just look for
anime uproar and follow us go right now
and vote you can download the app it's
totally free for iPhone or Android just
check the link in the description and a
big sincere thank you to Amino for
supporting more content here on anime
uproar to learn more about each Titans
unique abilities you can check out all
nine Titan shifters and their powers
explained which I'll link in the
description and at the end of this video
but this specific video will focus on
the users rather than on the powers we
are going to trace each power from as
far back as we know to the current user
questions around the Titan users often
come up in the comments so I'm hoping
that this video will clear things up if
you want to see more attack on Titan
content make sure to smash that like
button to let me know and make sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you never miss a new attack on Titan
video in this video I will occasionally
gesture towards other videos that will
give you additional information about
specific topics that you may be
interested in all of the mentioned
videos can be found linked in the
description finally there will be manga
spoilers ahead so proceed with
stream caution now without further ado
let's get to the first Titan the
founding Titan all of the nine Titan
powers were originally possessed by a
mere fritz the male version of history
argues that yamir made a deal with the
earth devil over 1,800 years ago and
that is why the LD ins or subjects of
yamir are also referred to as children
of the devil Ehren Kruger on the other
hand believes that yamir came into
contact with the source of all living
matter and in this way obtained her
powers as I mentioned before this sounds
a lot like when Edie came into contact
with the truth and Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and had to pay a price in
exchange for new powers in your mears
case she only lived thirteen years
before she died and this led to the
curse of yamir since no other Titan
shifter could be more powerful than
yamir a shifter must die within 13 years
of getting the power however we have
never actually seen a shifter die from
Ymir's curse yet they always passed the
power on beforehand so we aren't 100%
sure what exactly would happen
although Ehren Kruger believes that the
power would simply pass on to a random
newborn LDN anyways after he mere fritz
died the power of the founding titan was
kept in the royal Fritz family later
renamed the Reese family within the
walls on the island of parodies if we
take 1820 roughly the number of years
ago that yamir first gained the power of
the Titans and divided by 13 supposedly
the maximum lifespan of a shifter then
we get 140 so at the very least there
have been a hundred forty users of each
of the nine titan powers so that would
mean 1260 Titan users at least however
there were likely more since some people
probably did not keep the power for the
full 13 years they may have chosen to
pass it on sooner or had it stolen
against their will since memories of all
past users can be passed out to current
users that's an insane amount of
memories you are potentially dealing
with in
Garth's that our founding titan we don't
know of any users aside from you mere
fritz until we get to Karl Fritz the
145th king of aldia King Karl Fritz is
also referred to as the first King
because he was the one to move many of
the LD ins to Paradise Island and
created the three walls using tens of
millions of colossal Titans
he is also the one who used the power of
the founding Titan to erase the memories
of those same aliens so that they came
to believe they were the last remnants
of humanity and that there were only
Titans beyond the walls in order to
protect the true royal family he renamed
them from Fritz to Reese so they could
remain in hiding as Nobles while another
bloodline played the role of the royal
family within the walls
according to Willie Tiber about a
hundred years ago the LD and Empire was
using the power of the Titans to rule
the world
once the LD ins ran out of enemies they
began to kill one another which was the
beginning of the great Titan war while
the Royal Fritz family held the founding
tighten the other a Titans were held by
other families who continuously fought
each other over the remaining Titan
abilities and the power that would come
with them while previous founding titan
inheritors maintained balance among the
families and protected the LD and Empire
Carl Fritz
even before he inherited the founding
Titan power lamented the LDN empires of
brutal history the ugly wars fought
between families and countrymen and the
constant tyranny that the LD ins
inflicted on the nation of Marlay when
he inherited the Titan power he
conspired with one of the Titan families
the Tiber family who possessed the
Warhammer Titan and put an end to the
LDN Empire Carl and the Tiber z' worked
together to present halos that Marlon as
a hero while Carl moved to the island of
paradise and took as many LD ins as he
could with him he created the walls and
claimed that he would unleash the Titans
inside to flatten the earth if anyone
disturbed their peace but he didn't
actually mean this he renounced war
and made sure his philosophy would be
passed down to every royal blooded
inheritor of the founding titan since
only those of royal blood can use the
absolute power of the founding titan
carl thought that this would ensure that
the founding titan is never used against
other nations again his ultimate goal
was peace but Carl also accepted the
fact that Marlay might grow as a nation
and eventually exterminate all LD ins
including the royal family he believed
that the crimes that the LD ins
committed were so grave in the past that
they should have never existed in the
first place and could never atone for
their actions so their extermination was
justified however until that day of
extermination came he wanted to enjoy a
peaceful paradise inside the walls with
his people in this way the founding
titan power and the first king's own
pacifist ideology was passed down
through the generations we don't know of
any successors before mr. Reis who was
the father of Yuri Reis and rod Reis
historians father he inherited the first
King's ideology and refused to put a
stop to the Titan threat despite the
pleas of Yuri and rod he even appears to
have placed rod behind bars because of
his constant attempts to get him to kill
every single type afterwards yuri rods
younger brother inherited the power from
mr. Reis
just like carl fritz was determined to
put an end to the LDN Empire Yuri was
determined to save humanity from the
Titans before he inherited the power
however once he ate his father and
inherited the power he also inherited
Carl's ideology and as a result he
refused to save humanity from the Titans
or to tell anyone about the lost
memories of mankind eventually Kenny
Ackerman tracked Yuri down and tried to
kill him but Yuri was too powerful
instead of killing him Yuri spared him
Yuri felt that Kenny's actions were
justified because of all of the
persecution that the Ackerman's had
suffered because of the monarchy
afterwards
Kenny became Yuri's bodyguard and close
friend you
eventually passed out his power to his
niece Freda Reese Freda Reese was the
daughter of broad reefs and historias
older half-sister at the age of 15 she
injected herself with a titin serum and
as a mindless Titan ate her uncle
inheriting the founding Titan like Yuri
she believed that she could fight the
ideology of the first game she told rod
and I quote leave it to me father I
won't let the ghosts of our ancestors
get the better of me but she also
changed after inheriting the power and
adopted Carl's ideology Frieda used to
visit historian when she lived a lonely
existence on a farm but would erase her
memories afterwards
unlike Yuri who was calm most of the
time after inheriting the founding Titan
Frieda could get extremely emotional at
times like when historia told her that
she tried to cross the fence even though
she inherited the founding titan power
and the first kings will evidently that
did not affect how much she cared about
her half sister and her half sisters
safety she spent a lot of time with
historia and even taught her how to read
and write
eventually Gregor Erin's father stole
the power from Frieda using the attack
Titan all dull as rod points out
Frieda's Titan was the greatest of all
the Titans and possessed an invincible
power
Grishka was able to defeat her because
free to lack the experience necessary to
unleash the true abilities of the
founding type Grisha went on to kill
every other member of the Reese family
that was present except rod managed to
escape for the first time ever the
founding Titan was now inside someone
without royal blood
this meant that Grisha could not fully
use its power but it also meant that now
the holder of the founding Titan was not
controlled by the first Kings ideology
Grisha as an elder in restorationist
wanted the founding Titan power so that
he could help restore the LT and Empire
however he had already inherited the
attack-type in a while back and due to
your mirrors curse he could die soon and
lose both the attack
titin as a result he decides to entrust
his son Eren Jaeger with both powers
before his own time runs out
he takes air into the woods after the
events that took place in the Reese
Chapel where he ate Frieda injects Aaron
was a Titan serum and is eaten by his
son so Aaron is the current holder of
the founding Titan like Grisha he was
unable to use the ability at first but
eventually he realized that when he
comes into contact with a royal blooded
Titan like the smiling Titan I'll put a
link in the description for a video that
explains everything
you need to know about the smiling Titan
then he can use the founding Titan power
thus there is a way to use the founding
Titan power and yet not be affected by
the first Kings ideology currently in
the manga Aaron and Zeke Yeager the
current possessor of the Beast Titan are
on the same side so that Aaron could
technically stand on top of Zeke's
beasts Titans shoulder and use all the
founding Titans abilities I still can't
wait to see this happen the attack Titan
next we'll look at the known users of
the attack Titan the known first user of
the attack Titan since Jameer Fritz is
Aaron Krueger who also went by the
codename owl
Kruger's father joined an insurgent
force that was created by members of the
Royal Fritz family who stayed on the
continent their plans were discovered by
Marlon public security authorities and
they were all burned alive with their
families as a child who resembled our
protagonist Eren Yeager by the way he
saw his family being burned alive
through a crack in a closet that is the
day he swore to get revenge on Marley
and restore Elvia he was able to get an
LD and doctor to take his blood test
convincing the authorities that he was
an LD n Kruger was able to join the
Marlin public security authorities and
work as a spy for the LD and
restorationist under the name the owl in
order to maintain the trust of Marley
and served the LDN cause he had to
torture and kill many LD ins and he did
it without showing any out
signs of empathy for instance he beat up
a child Grisha and failed to do anything
to save his sister from a brutal death
eventually he secretly gained the power
of the attack Titan and when his 13
years were running out he chose to pass
the power along with his hope for aldea
- Grisha Jaeger Grisha was chosen in
part because Kruger noticed his hatred
for Marlay when Grisha was still a child
after the marlon officer killed his
sister
Fay Jaeger because of the cruel
treatment that LD ins experienced on
there Marlon rule Grisha decided to join
the LD and restorationist he married the
Royal blooded Dean of Fritz and had a
child called Zeek Yeager who he
volunteered to be a Marlon warrior so
that he could serve as an LD in Mol
however Zeke told the Marlins about his
parents and the other LD and
restorationist which led to their
capture Grisha and the other LD ins are
taken to paradise island where the
Marlins inject LD ends with tightened
spinal fluid and throw them down a large
wall close to the ocean where they're
doomed to roam searching for humans to
devour
however Grisha is saved by Kruger who
kills all the Marlins and entrusts
Grisha with the attack Titan and his
mission Grisha accepts and uses the
Titan power to make it near the inner
walls where he is discovered by Keith
sadhus he pretends to have amnesia and
slowly learns the way of life inside the
walls he starts working as a doctor like
he was in Marlay when an epidemic breaks
out of chigan Sheena Grisha finds a cure
and is able to save the afflicted
including Carla and her parents
afterwards
Grisha and Carla marry and have Erin
most likely named after Aaron Krueger
who eventually inherits the attack Titan
power along with the founding Titan from
his father
Grisha passes on Aaron Krueger's name
and mission to his son along with the
Titan powers currently Aaron is still in
possession of the attack Titan power and
has used it successfully in countless
situations including to help plug holes
in the walls and to help defeat the
female Titan the armored Titan and most
recently the
hammer tighten the jaw tighten the
earliest possessor of the jaw Titan
powered that we know of is Marcel
Galliard
the older brother of Porco Galliard
Marcel was an LDN who was born in Marlay
his parents entered him and his brother
Porco into a Merlin program where LD ins
would train and compete in order to
inherit one of the titan powers and
become as a result honorary Merlin's
along with their families strong
reliable and quick-witted he excelled in
the program and earned the honor of
inheriting the jaw Titan power he went
along with Reiner Annie and Bethel to
Paradise Island on a mission to bring
back the founding Titan however on the
way to the walls a mindless Titan takes
the group by surprise and is about to
eat reiner when Marcel pushes him out of
the way and sacrifices his own life to
save whiners this mindless Titan turns
out to be yamir the Future survey Corps
member now whenever I name the nine
Titans I always get some people
commenting that I forgot to dancing
Titan referring to Ymir's Titan but in
reality what people refer to as the
dancing Titan is simply Ymir's version
of the jaw Titan if you want to learn
about what happened to your mirror
before she became a mindless Titan you
can check out your mirror and the jaw
Titan explained here I'll be looking at
what happened after she inherited the
power she roamed around as a mindless
Titan for 60 years before she ate Marcel
which turned her into a human with the
ability to shift into the jaw Titan
notably she clearly doesn't look older
than 60 so humans don't actually age
while in mindless Titan form which is
pretty interesting she lived as a thief
in wall Sheena and then overheard a
conversation about crystalens aka
historia and this letter to join the
military
yamir uses the jaw Titan power to save
historia and other recruits at food
guard castle from the surrounding pure
Titans later after Aaron makes contact
with the smiling Titan and uses the
founding Titan power to make this
surrounding pure Titans attack Reiner in
Bethel yamir decides to use the jaw
Titan to help save the tumour laying
warriors
although Reiner gives her a chance to
leave after they escape the pure Titans
yamir declines she says that she is
tired and she wants to repay the debt
because their arrival to parody's freed
her from an endless nightmare referring
to the time she spent as a mindless
tightening she knows that the two cannot
go back empty-handed so she decides to
play the goddess as she says and act
selflessly so that they may be spared
they bring her back to Marlay where
Porco Galliard eats her and inherits a
job Titan power Porco is the current
user of the JA titan power and he used
it successfully in wars against Marlys
enemies such as in the Battle of Fort
Slava where he destroyed the enemy's
railways and anti-titan artillery with
his Titans powerful jaw although he puts
up a good fight against Aaron's attack
Titan in male his jaw Titan is
ultimately defeated by Eren and Mikasa
combined effort nonetheless Porco with
riders help managed to maintain
possession of the jaw Titan power the
armored Titan the current and only known
holder of the armored Titan power is
Reiner riders mother was an LVN but his
father was Marlon Reiner worked hard in
the Marlon warrior program hoping that
he could inherit one of the Titan powers
so that he and his mom could become
honorary Marlins and be reunited with
his Marlon father
Reiner only made it as far as he did
because he demonstrated exceptional
loyalty for Marlay on the written
component of the examination in the
other areas Reiner was behind the other
warrior candidates if it wasn't for
Marcel Porco would have likely inherited
the armored Titan in Ryder's place
because Reiner ranked at the bottom of
the group
however Porco spoke highly of Reiner and
spoke badly of his brother Porco in
order to protect his brother from
inheriting a Titan power and dying
within 13 years if not sooner as a
result Reiner succeeded inheriting the
armored Titan although when he finally
confronted his father his father made it
clear that he wanted nothing to do with
him or his mother the honorary Marlin
status meant absolutely nothing to him
since inheriting the power Reiner has
used the armored Titan to help his
Marlin team breach the walls on paradise
by ramming through wall Maria's gate to
repeatedly battle the attack Titan and
the survey Corps to help defeat Marley's
enemy nations and to rescue Porco and
the jaw Titan from being consumed by
Aaron during the battle in Marlay
despite all he's been through Reiner has
been able to retain possession of the
armored Titan both Falco and Gabby have
been competing over who will inherit the
armored Titan but since they are both
currently on the run on Paradise Island
it appears Reiner won't be passing it
down anytime soon if you want a more
detailed breakdown of riders backstory
and character you can check out my
Reiner and the armored Titan explained
video the colossal Titan Berthold Hoover
is the earliest known holder of the
colossal Titan power he along with
Reiner acquired the power through the
Marlin warrior program he traveled to
parodies with the rest of the Marlin
team and used the colossal Titan power
to break through shegaon Shiina
district's gate Berthold uses the
colossal Titan power against the survey
Corps until he finally loses it in the
return to chigan Sheena Ark Armin and
Aran combine their efforts and managed
to defeat Ben thoughts colossal Titan
but Armin is badly burned in the process
leaving him close to death in order to
save Armin he is given a Titan serum and
in pure Titan form devours Berthold
inheriting his colossal Titan power
after to return to shegaon Shiina arc
armin uses the colossal titan power in
order to help Aaron deal with enemy
ships approaching Paradise Island later
in Marlay he uses the colossal Titans
explosion ability to destroy Marlies
naval reinforcements it is also revealed
that Armin visits annie in her Chris
form given Armand's pre-existing
relationship with Annie and combined
that with the memory you see inherited
from bad saled who loved Annie and you
get a character who likely has extremely
strong feelings towards Annie I look
forward to seeing how the relationship
between Armand and Annie will develop
but first she needs to get out of that
crystal this brings us nicely to the
next Titan power the female Titan the
current and only known user of the
female Titan power is Annie lone heart
she also inherited her Titan power
because she excelled in the Merlin
warrior program she went along with
Reiner Marcel and battle to Paradise
Island in order to retrieve the founding
Titan she used the female Titans power
to attract pure Titans to her Titan form
so that these Titans would fill into the
shegaon chena district after battle
destroyed the gate during the initial
Marlin attack although her secret Titan
identity was the first to be discovered
and she was the first to be defeated by
eren's Titan and Mikasa she still
managed to maintain possession of her
Titan power by surrounding herself with
a hard protective crystal she is
currently being held underground by the
survey Corps during the battle of Marlay
the Warhammer Titan user used the same
crystal ability and we learned that the
jaw Titan power can actually break
through this seemingly impregnable
crystal but the survey Corps failed to
take the jaw tightened power so for the
time being the female Titan power seems
to be safe inside Annie
the Beast Titan the current and only
known user of the Beast Titan power is Z
Jaeger the son of Grisha a gir and Deena
Fritz and Eren Yeager's half-brother he
was entered into the Marla Warrior
Program by Grisha who as we learned was
an LD in restorationist
and wished to plant his son as an LD
inspire thin the Marlon military however
one day zeke appeared to betray his
parents and rat them out along with
other LD and restorationist s-- recently
in the manga Zeke has claimed that the
Marlon military was extremely close to
figuring out about
Aldi and restorationist and probably
about Zeke's and his mother's royal
blood as well
if the merlion army did inevitably find
out the truth on their own they would
have killed the restorationist along
with their families Zeke and his
grandparents would have probably been
killed as well
Zeke's mother because of her royal blood
may have been kept alive for breeding
purposes so that Marla could raise loyal
royal blooded ldiots who could
eventually inherit the founding titan
power instead kid Zeke for the Greater
Albion cost told on his parents so he
could hide his royal identity and retain
his position as an LD and restorationist
within the Marlon military Zeke was the
first in the merlion warrior program to
inherit a Titan power which also means
that he has the least time left to live
because of your mirrors curse probably
less than a year at this point since the
survey Corps needs a royal blooded
tighten too activate Aaron's founding
Titan powers it appears that the Royal
blooded historia and her children will
be the subsequent inheritors of the
Beast Titan power if you want a closer
look at Zeke and the beast Titan
definitely check out the beast Titan
explained the cart Titan the current and
only known user of the car Titan is
piqué piqué is the last character on
this list who inherited her Titan power
from the Marlin warrior program peak
stood out in the warrior program because
of her intelligence she was given the
cart Titan specifically because she
showed strong judgment Peake has
definitely used her power successfully
it was peak in her cart Titan form who
managed to save and retrieve Zeke and
Reiner during the battle at chignon
sheena the car titan is also the only
Titan we've seen up to this point that
has military artillery attached to it
during battle which is pretty cool
although she was badly injured in the
battle at Marlay in Chapter 107 she is
shown with Reiner and Porco and she
appears to be fully recovered Marlay is
only in possession of these three Titans
now the card Titan the armored Titan and
the jaw Titan
the warhammer tighten now we've reached
the final tighten power which was the
last one to be revealed in the manga the
Warhammer Titan power was similar to the
founding titan power in that for a long
time it was passed down within one
family in the case of the Warhammer
Titan power it was passed down within
the Tiber family for generations
the earliest known possessor of the
Warhammer Titan was Willy Tiber sister
who remains unnamed the Tiber sister is
introduced in chapter 101 and is killed
in chapter 104 although she put up a
great fight against Aaron's attack Titan
Mikasa shows up and completely turns the
tide of the battle Aaron finds the Tiber
sister's body in a protective crystal
and manages to break it using the jaw
Titans mouth as a nutcracker now there
has been some speculation as to who
inherited the Warhammer Titan power
since we haven't seen anyone use it yet
some people initially thought that Porco
might have ingested the Warhammer Titans
spinal fluid and inherited the power
rather than Aaron but this does not seem
to be the case in Chapter 107 Aaron
seems to confirm that he has the
Warhammer Titan and he says that he can
use it to get out of jail whenever he
wants furthermore in Chapter 107 Aaron
talks to himself in a mirror telling
himself repeatedly to fight almost as if
convincing himself
hanji notes that she has never heard him
talking to himself before one theory is
that Aaron is trying to maintain control
over all of the memories and identities
that are inside him right now as I
mentioned each Titan Power had at least
140 prior users and these memories are
passed down to the current user this
would mean that Aaron with his three
Titan powers inside him currently has at
least 420 people's memories and
personalities somewhere inside him
I think this would explain in part why
he's been acting strange and talking to
himself but let me know what you think
in the comments and that is it for
today's video
I hope you enjoyed hearing about all the
known users of the nine Titan powers if
you did definitely give that like button
a colossal Warhammer smash let me know
who your favorite Titan user past or
present is in the comments below and why
I'd like to hear your thoughts don't
forget to vote for which video you would
like to see next and if for some reason
you still haven't subscribed make sure
you do and hit that notification bell so
you don't miss a new attack on titan
video until next time see ya space
cowboys
[Music]
you